3-0-1.
AS WE TOLD YOU THE RED WINGS GEO
NOT BIG IN STATURE, BUT WORKS
HARD, DOESN'T BACK DOWN FROM SU.
APPLETON TOOK THE ROUTE THOUGH,
MICK, YES, SEIDER LEANEDBLOCK C.
THE SHOT.
>> THAT HIT SEIDER?
>> I THINK, THERE'S WHY.
IT IS OFFSIDE.
>> YEP.
>> I TELL YOU WHAT HAPPENED
HERE.
YOU BACK ITTO BE A GREAT YEP.
WE HOPE NOT.
>> POWER PLAY TIPPED UP
GOALS THIS SEASON FOR THIS LOW,.
THAT SHOT GOT GRUBAUER, HIT THE
POST, SUTER BACK TO LARKIN, H I.
HERE'S JOHOHMARC STAAL.
HE DID WHAT HE THOUG
THEY'VE HAD A COUPLE OF GAMES
CANCELED DUE TO
PUCK.
REFEREES THOUGHT OTHER THEN IT'S
AN ODD MAN BY
HE'S GOT HIS 99th CAREER GOAL.
>> MICHAEL OF THE MONTH LAST
THEY HAVEN'T TAKEN A DIP AT ALL
IN THEIR PLAY.
>> 41
TO KNOW WHAT IT IS.
>> RIGHT.
BIT OF ASON ABLE TO F F AGAIN.
FABBRI SECONDS LEFT. I THINK TH.
>> I THINK IT ERNE.
SCORES!
>>